he is Howard Reynolds how are you HR I'm
doing fine better talking to you right
now so let's get into it what I had to
look up Lewis Rojas I'm being very
honest with you I'm not very well aware
of who quality control coaches are
despite their potential famous family
lineage but I give you the floor on what
you think of the Mets hire well first of
all he's Felipe alou's son so the great
manager is one of his sons that's just
made his mother's name
so come when Philippe came to America
they grabbed the Alou name it's actually
felipe rojas Alou and so the young guy
stayed with rojas but he's worked his
way through the minor leagues with the
Mets he knows basically the whole roster
he's managed in costume I've heard
nothing but great things about him as
far as being a field general and
understand we have a baseball so they're
excited about it
I've been hearing this for about a week
I had to figure out who he was myself
and the background and where he comes
from
so I mean he there's a media aspect to
this too and and and I'm hoping he's
ready for that also cuz this is this is
the deep end of a baseball pool manager
of him New York Metropolitan's certainly
after Carlos Beltran didn't even manage
a game Harold I mean is there any sense
on how he might handle that yeah very
well very articulate speaks English
quite well it's obviously fluent in
Spanish but he's handled the media
before and they just feel like the
pedigree had grown up in that family
around his dad Felipe and spending time
there but he's been through a lot I
think the big thing no they stayed
within the organization and they felt
like that opportunity to go other ways
and he just was a guy that stood out for
a long time when they went to the
process not too long ago to hire Beltran
in the first place he was one of the
guys that they had considered and they
were going to try to bring him along
little bit slower in the organization
but obviously once belt I was not able
to handle the the reins anymore they
felt like it was just
to go ahead and keep the continent going
and they felt like this kid was ready
yeah I guess so
I mean there's a big step man there's a
huge step and especially with the
firestorm that he's coming in and you
know having to deal with New York is a
lot different than say Seattle no
offense but I played there long enough
of course there's a lot more media and a
lot more scrutiny in New York and he's
got to answer some tough questions
everything on it and we'll see how he
gets to that place well at least you
know he is totally removed from anything
that had anything to do with the Astros
in 2017 or anything with with any of
this I mean he just came into the major
leagues as the quality control coach
just last season so and he's in-house
he's one of their own and look I mean
you could look around so many sports
where let's go for the guy who was the
young guy who's got a lot on the ball
who's sharp who can communicate with
anybody in our locker room or clubhouse
when it comes to baseball and before
somebody snaps him up when he's
supposedly quote-unquote ready let's
let's get him right now I mean that that
might be the scenario that the Mets are
taking up here HR yeah but one thing
that gives it a little bit of a pause is
the mesophyll to win right now you know
this isn't let's ride along with our new
manager and we'll figure it out in two
or three years the groms ready you got
to figure out what you're gonna do a
syndergaard this team is built to jump
into and what looks like right now for
me the best division in baseball is the
National League East is a beast so he's
got to be ready and he's got a club
that's that's gonna be demanding wins
this is not going to be a rebuild at New
York so it's a different scenario so you
think the NL AC occurs Girardi's now
with the Phillies we all know that the
defending World Series champions are are
in that division
you've got the Mets clearly and the
Braves and how terrific a season they
had until their disaster in the playoffs
I mean you're you're right there I mean
and what do you think the Astros and the
Red Sox are going to do with their
vacancies
that is still to be determined I know
the Red Sox will sell it the Sox I don't
know where they're going yet I'm feeling
like with it with high emblem the new
general manager he's going to go with
somebody he knows and he's trying to get
the guy I've heard from Tampa that was
the bench coach but I don't know I think
it's gonna be somebody he's very with
it's a different scenario than it is
with Houston III because he's got to
build a whole new culture and you're
looking at the Red Sox really started to
turn things over a little bit more savor
metrically with time there and so I
think he's going to look for a more
sabermetric minded manager Alex Cora was
Mary with the numbers use them
occasionally but he was more of a gun he
was more old-school and he had a lot
more control over that organization most
managers now front offices are sending
down lineups they're helping order and
direct how games are ran so I think
you're going to see a lot more hands on
in Boston in Houston told them a
scenario you know they're in the fire
right now yeah because they had their
their manager and the general manager
and all the things a commissioner
brought down on them I think they got to
go with an experienced guy and I to me I
think Buck Showalter is a perfect fit
you know you've been from from New York
rich when George Steinbrenner got
suspended for baseball buck was the
manager a lot of these different things
were happening Steve Howe got suspended
all those times buck was the manager you
know so he's been through the storm he's
built organizations so I think he's the
perfect fit for that organization right
now for what they need yeah because
certainly a higher they're the higher
they're more than you know obviously
we're still waiting to hear from the
commissioner how Reynolds here from MLB
Network on the richezza we're still
waiting here from the Commissioner on
what what what the 2018 Red Sox were
either up to or not the hiring Houston
is so important I mean so important
where we just got to figure we got to
get rid of all the trash cans and all
the thorough guns and all
that might have been going on there in
2017 and whatever the the mindset that
that there's no other way to put it
metastasized in 2017 that other teams
might have employed in 2018 or not that
that whatever went there needs to be
wiped clean and then come up with a
scenario where where all the players say
something other than what Bregman said
about you know he kind of pulled a
Maguire I'm out here to talk about the
past at fan fest and Altuve saying I
didn't wear any buzzers or anything like
that but everything else I'm not ready
to talk about you've got to come up with
a plan in Houston from the manager to
what the players are saying to get this
thing in a different direction Harold
what he'll slowly agree that you know
what they did at fan fest is not gonna
work
and that was ill-advised I don't know
who was advising them at that time but
they gotta come clean or it's gonna
linger forever on the rest of their
resume as a team everything moving
forward so they gotta have that address
when they get the spring training but
it's a different scenario in Houston in
my mind because you got rid of the
general manager and the manager you know
they don't have a general manager and so
I know the owner and that what they've
built there with there's new systems of
feeling like they were very sabermetric
and they're scouting department and
player development and everything is
very reliant on that you want to have
somebody that doesn't upset that
applecart because they really do have
great players so that's a whole
different thing and that to me that's
that's why you got to have that guy that
sits in front of the media that manager
after every game and he's credible and
that's why I think buck so alters the
guy
Howard Reynolds here on the Rich Eisen
show okay you're gonna have Jeter and
Larry Walker later on today at 5:30 cool
man
you know it's talking about I was
talking about earlier the speeches in
the meadow in Cooperstown this summer
you're gonna have somebody like in a way
corporate America with Jeter and then
you're gonna have Larry Walker showing
up and I guess in a spongebob shirt
maybe you know you got a contrast in in
in this class right here Harold
going to be blessed you know well that's
what's cool about it plus you know I
mean all in New York's going it's gonna
be amazing it will be the largest crowd
in in Cooperstown history I know that
they had some great crowds of Mariano
and with with Ripken and Gwyn at the
same time but you know Derek Jeter is
everything from New York and Beyond and
Larry Walker's from Canada and so you're
gonna have a lot of folks coming down
from nearby Canada and Montreal and
whatnot to come down as well so it's
gonna be an enormous crowd and it's
going to be a fun fun time do we know
who the individual that did not vote for
Jeter is a Hall of Famer do we know
where that person is hell haven't heard
yet but I'm sure they're searching for
him all over the place him or her I just
hope that they voted because they just
felt like he wasn't qualified to be a
Hall of Famer
okay that's your opinion that's what you
want to say but I sure hope it's not a
publicity stunt and it will be fleshed
out in due time and and that will be a
conversation to be had but I want an
individual and I'd love it there what
they were thinking yeah the only one
that that my prediction is you're gonna
hear well Ripken didn't go in and all
these others didn't go in as unanimous
at the shortstop position and I didn't
feel that Jeter was better than them so
I couldn't vote for for Jeter and to me
that just makes no sense I mean
everybody should be in its own world in
its own time in its own place judged on
whether there is the person worthy of
the Hall of Fame or not and I know it
took a little Walker all the way to the
very end of his eligibility to finally
get that consensus but somebody like
Jeter there's just I mean you can't tell
the story the Yankees can't tell the
story of that part of the the the
century without without him
I mean it's nuts yeah and you know and
watch him play really wants to grow up
you know we spent time together covering
from 96 on and then you know fall in
love at that core for the Yankees and
the biggest thing when you look back at
Derek's legacy he did it through
the controversy you look at all the
players that spelled there in that time
the steroid era he stayed clean and
trust me they were looking you know and
and he stayed clean through the whole
thing I think that is a tribute to him
and the player that he has to put up the
numbers and all that so I think that
stands for something as well but you're
dead on you're probably right somebody
if Willie Mays 100% house he if couch
policy so I you can be absolutely right
but what we'll see I mean we're gonna
hear from this individual and I just
wonder what they have the say what do
you think his legacy is what's used
legacy I think it's one of the greatest
players in history and his impact is
gonna be everlasting I mean it's it's
Mickey Mantle it's it's one of the
biggest Yankees ever and I think maybe
bigger in this sense that we live in a
different time than in the 40s and the
50s with DiMaggio and met on all those
guys because of social media and the
reach of how you can reach not only New
York or baseball fans but globally you
know Derek Jeter walks down the street
people know who he is my child walks
down the street people know do not
recognize him as much and Mickey Mantle
COO they would they would never know and
had he walked down the street in Oregon
when I was growing up as a kid I never
saw him I just heard about him I read
about it you know so that's how things
have changed so much but he transcends
the game of baseball and it was
interesting real quick I'll just close
out there sure I I'm curious what's
going to happen on an induction day I
mean that's a guy then I was fortunate
to really get to know and I hosted his
events in Gulf and Tampa for 10 straight
years and we had John Legend saying we
had boys two men just at his wedding
he knows jay-z then at his defense you
know there's no telling who's gonna be
there he's interviewed Obama he was on
Saturday Night Live I mean he
transcended so many things outside of
baseball this is a very unique baseball
player we might see it in other sports
you don't see that in baseball well I've
already volunteered my services for
induction day Harold
earlier in the show I said that whoever
did not vote for Derrick should be found
and then forced to present Jeter at the
Hall of Fame reading comments written by
me personally I would write them well
that person the remarks were to go
something along the lines of here's
Derek Jeter baseball hall-of-famer I
suck
that's basically what it would basically
read ask the poll question of HR before
we send him on to again have both Derek
Jeter and Larry Walker on MLB Network
studio 42 on MLB tonight at 5:30 p.m.
Eastern what do you got over there HR
who's most deserving of Hall of Fame
enshrined meant some of the guys who
aren't in Pete Rose Barry Bonds and
Roger Clemens none of the above
all of the above whoo I have a hard time
with Pete Rose not being in the Hall of
Fame and I understand I probably get
crushed by a lot of people but four
thousand two hundred fifty six heads and
I know the gambling thing came as a
manager so as far as I know he could
have been gambling as a player too but I
just think that as time comes I'm
watching the softening stance of bonds
and Clemens with steroids and I think
people are blasting over Pete Rose and
and and and that with the world changing
the way it is III think Pete's gotta be
in the Hall fan thanks Harold again
we'll see on MLB tonight tonight at 5:30
Eastern with both Jeter and Walker it'll
be a fun show I'll be tuned in well chat
soon all right - thank you that's how
Reynolds here on the Rich Eisen show for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show app